we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 for 750
who's on with me next yes hello Taylor
to secure it from downingtown PA what's
up Jared what's on your mind today I'm
actually sort of in a moral dilemma here
okay six days left until the election
not even and think of you though let me
give you the rundown I voted for the
first in the first presidential election
in 2012 and you know who I voted for no
i don't oh well do I have that written
down here hold on oh no I thought for a
second I thought I might have written
down who you voted for but I don't I
wish they had a data bank for example if
I keep track my votes they were counted
but uh no I voted for Jill Stein ok arm
I was very disappointed with Obama I
actually said I would never vote for him
after he passed the NDAA in two thousand
the 2012 NDAA and I just assumed he was
gonna win anyway and I yeah I didn't
really see a difference between him and
Romney for the most part ok and i assume
Pennsylvania would go blue because I
just assumed just based off
Pennsylvania's voting history and now
I'm sort of in the same dilemma i was in
2012 I mean I did attend about an obama
rally you know my family's democratic
you know I've always been a liberal my
hair life and I attack tell everybody
you know oh I'm gonna vote for Hillary
but thinking I just feel dirty if I do
vote for her yeah we'll listen I will
you feel dirtier will you feel dirtier
if Trump wins Pennsylvania by a vote I
work yet so then vote for Hillary I
think event or question you you'll feel
dirty voting for Hillary but you'll feel
dirtier if Trump wins by one vote and
that your vote for jill stein instead of
Hillary so I think you I don't think my
presence is needed in this one I think
you figured it out for yourself there
okay David I will I will I will look at
the polls remember november eight and i
will make my decision that but i am i'm
leaning towards Hillary now but I i
might go first on I don't know you're
alright well let us know your decision
uh I trust that you will do the right
thing and uh we'll see what happens in
Pennsylvania I I hope Pennsylvania's not
close but there are some who say some
have said Trump's talking to people all
over the place who are telling him that
it's super-close in Pennsylvania so I'd
vote for Hillary unless you want to risk
a trump victory